[Applause]
I grew up on a beef Farm in Missouri and
like everybody else that raises
livestock we raise a lot of our own feed
to stay in business and we raise corn
and soybeans and hay and we grind this
stuff up into a flower and we'd add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
make pellets you feed those Cals for
about six nine months and then you ship
them off to be butchered or maybe to
other feeders and you always save back
the very best ones for yourself and you
knock them in the head and eat them it's
a real simple cycle on the farm and the
thing that fascinated me as a teenager
was that we went to a great deal of
trouble for those calves and yet as a
family we ate out of the very same
Fields we'd keep back five rows of corn
for oursel we had a garden at the end of
the field where we grew our peas and
beans and squash and tomatoes and we
wanted to live to be a hundred with no
aches and pains and we didn't give
ourselves the very same vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals that we gave
the calves and I always used to ask my
dad I say hey Pops how come we go to all
that trouble for those calves and and
not far s and he'd say shut up boy
getting Farm Fresh Food fresh air lots
of free exercise don't ask complicated
questions and I was glad to get rid of
the farm exercise and go to a school at
the University of Missouri and there my
major was in animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and I began to learn technical
things about soil chemistry and how it
related to tons and bushels per acre and
a economics but I didn't get an answer
to my basic question until I became a
freshman Veterinary student at the
University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds bottom line
is because we don't have insurance for
them we don't have Blue Cross Blue
Shield major medical hospitalization
Medicare Medicaid and if we were to use
a human health care type of system for
Animals it'd be sticker shock for you
your hamburger would cost you $275 a
pound boneless skinless chicken breast
would be 450 bucks a pound dozen eggs
would be $50 just to pay for the health
care so we learned that we could keep
the price of animal products such as
meat and dairy and poultry and eggs down
to where the average American could
afford them simply by significantly
reducing or totally eliminating health
care cost and we do that in Animals by
preventing and curing diseases with
nutrition well after graduating vet
school I went to Africa for a couple of
years and got to work with Marlon
Perkins from the old Mutual of Omaha
Wild Kingdom days that was kind of a
kick got to play Frank Buck use a
tranquilizer gun tromp all over Central
and South Africa for a couple of years
and then Marlon sent me a telegram and
invited me back to the States uh he'd
gotten a $7.5 million Grant from the
National Institutes health and this was
more than 30 years ago and this was to
study pollution and ecology and the
environment and my job as the Wildlife
veterinarian on the project was to do
autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States and I was supposed to
identify or find a species of animals
who was Ultra sensitive to pollution and
we're going to use that animal much like
the old coal miners used to use canaries
you know how that goes they take the
canary down in the mine and if methane
gas or carbon monoxide were to leak into
the mine the canaries were more sens
sensitive than the men and would drop
off the Persian die and long before the
men were in danger of suffocating or
blowing up well to make a long story
short after some 12 plus years of
working on this project and done some
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals plus 3,000 human beings for a
comparison and what I learned was that
every animal and human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency disease and I got kind of
excited about nutrition again and I
wrote 75 scientific papers on the
subject uh wrote chapters for eight
multi-author textbooks actually
contributed a textbook myself a th Pages
2,000 illustrations and uh through the
news releases that were in the big
universities I worked with I was on 2020
was in 1700 newspapers around the world
through the UPI and AP newswire services
and with all this public exposure and
with all this scientific exposure I
couldn't get people who are in a
position of authority either in medical
research or in politics you get too
concerned interested in preventing and
curing diseases in human beings with
nutrition just like we did in animals
well I got frustrated enough I went back
to school in Portland argon became a
physician and I practiced there for 12
years as a general family practitioner
and Uh I seed up chainsaw wounds
delivered babies um used everything that
I'd learned in Veterinary nutrition of
my human patients and it was no surprise
to me that it worked just as well in
people as it did in animals well to get
started I always like to talk about
longevity and the human being has the
genetic potential to live healthfully to
be 120 I'm going to prove that to you in
just a minute unfortunately Americans do
a lousy job when it comes to longevity
our average lifespan the United States
is 75.5 about half we're genetically
capable of in 1990 when the World Health
Organization examined the top 32
industrialized nations on Earth the
United States came out 17th there's
actually 16 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do we ranked
19th in healthfulness that meant that
there were 18 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do before
they develop heart disease and cancer
and diabetes and arthritis and
osteoporosis we ranked 23rd when it came
to live births and first year surviv
abilities of babies and we ranked dead
last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth effects now what all
this means is we have the highest priced
Health Care system in the world but not
the best it also means that we have the
most envied Health Care system in the
world but not the best we have the most
technologically advanced Health Care
system in the world but not the best I
had a good friend by the name of
Christopher bird from many many years
over 20 years and Chris was a
bestselling author on books on argle
grown food he was an expert in this
subject and I was always trying to give
him vitamins and minerals and he refused
to take them and he'd tell me Doc I
bring my own cooler I don't eat any uh
Hotel food I bring my own organically
grown food and so I don't need to take
vitamins and minerals well I was
changing planes again in Atlanta had an
hour to kill picked up the local
newspaper and guess whose obituary I
found in the newspaper Chris bird of
course again he was a bestselling author
of books The Secret Life of plants the
secrets of the soil and he died at age
68 from a ruptured aneurysm a type of
stroke 7 and A2 years before the average
American dies and he led a pristine life
lived up in the mountains had an
organically grown Garden collected herbs
you know like Ule Gibbons and ate wild
Hickory nuts and all those kind of
things and because of his belief he died
of a copper deficiency and I'll show you
in a minute that copper deficiency
causes ruptured aneurysms it's just a
tragic thing that that people have so
much to give and die at less than half
their genetic potential for longevity a
lot of people say to me Doc I don't need
to take vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals because I use herbs now herbs
are not nutrition you have to understand
that herbs are not nutrition they are
great plant medicines uh they're safer
they're more economical and most cases
are more effective than prescription
medications that doctors will give you
but they're plant medicines if you have
diarrhea they can tighten you up if you
have constipation they can loosen you up
if you have hypertension or high blood
pressure they can bring it down if you
have a fever and bring it down but don't
expect to get enough calcium or selenium
or Boron or copper or vitamin A from
herbs well I've been doing biomedical
research and Clinical Research in
animals and human beings and I can tell
you no matter how you look at Health and
Longevity whether it be an animals or
human beings there's only really two
concepts you have to deal with Concept
number one I refer to is avoid stepping
on the landmines this is where you don't
want to throw away your Healthy physical
body wastefully you don't want to smoke
don't abuse alcohol don't do drugs don't
jog down the highway at 2 o'clock in the
morning wearing an all black ninja suit
you're going to get hit by a truck
mirror right whenever a doctor says
here's our options never say Doc
whatever to say you're the you're the
doctor when a doctor says here's our
options what you want to do is say look
I want copies of all these records and
tests I want copies of the xrays and go
visit three other doctors and three
other hospitals you want to talk to 12
of their living patients that had gone
through this procedure talk to them see
if you really want to do this I mean you
do this for your driveway and your roof
and your fence and your yard and all
that kind of stuff why not for your own
physical body that's concept number one
now that you've avoided the landmines
you're in a good position to do all the
positive things that you need to do to
go on to live to be over 100
basically what you want to do is take
all the essential nutrients 60 that's 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatty acids
they're called essential nutrients for
two reasons number one your body cannot
manufacture them you must consume these
every day either as food or supplements
number two if any one of these essential
nutrients is missing for a couple of
months couple of years you get on the
average 10 deficiency diseases you have
everything to gain nothing to lose by
supplementing properly well the medical
profession of course has this malignant
dumb belief that you can get everything
you need from your four food groups my
favorite AR of all time in the Press was
April 6 1992 Time Magazine cover article
the real power of vitamins new research
shows it may help fight cancer heart
disease and the ravages of Aging six
positive Pages if you haven't read it
I'd urge you to go to a public library
School library dig it out and read it
there was only one negative sentence in
as you might guest it was offered by a
medical doctor who was actually uh
contacted by the writer of the article
said what do you think about vitamins
and minerals and and trace minerals as
supplements for human nutrition here's
what he said quote popping vitamins
doesn't do you any good sniffs Dr Victor
Herbert a professor of medicine at New
York City's Mount siai medical school we
get all the vitamins we need in our
diets and taking supplements just gives
you expensive urine unquote now Missouri
translation of that is you're just
peeing away your money you might as well
W up your dollars throw them in a toilet
and flush them away you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups is what he's trying to say well
I'd rather pee out 50 cents or a dollar
a day worth of excess vitamins and
minerals that's cheap insurance think
about it how much money you spend for
coffee or soft drinks or newspapers and
that kind of stuff every day 50 cents to
a dollar a day to maintain and repair
your body and it's kind of fascinating
that most people don't do it just
remember when you pay that doctor out of
your own pocket or indirectly through
insurance or indirectly through taxes
Medicare Medicaid not a single penny of
that goes to better understand manage
treat prevent or cure catastrophic
diseases in kids breast cancer in women
prostate cancer and men now a lot of
people ask me why did you call your
original tape Dead Doctors Don't Lie
well that's because I I believe for a
long time because i' done medical
research for over 20 years in large
medical research Institutes medical
schools the various Laboratories and I
always had a belief in the medical
system but I was very disappointed when
I learned that doctors don't know the
most about Health and Longevity doctors
don't know the most about disease they
do know about procedures you know how to
fix your bones when you break them and
that sort of thing how to do a CAT scan
and so I began to look in the medical
journals and sure enough the first
article ever published on Health and
Longevity of American doctors was
published in jamama in June 15th 1895 a
little over 100 years ago they said at
that time doctors lived to be 54 .6 I
redid the study 97 years later using the
same obituary techniques that they did
in jamama This was um January 20th 1993
that particular issue of jamama and it
turned out the doctors lived to be 57.6
I rounded up to 58 to give them the
benefit of the doubt and doctors just
went berserk when I said that I mean
this was the most outrageous thing that
they ever heard my principle is my my
premise is that doctors don't live as
long as the average couch potato in
America and I purposely put that figure
out there at 58 to try and challenge
people well doctors immediately looked
at all the insurance Actuarial charts
they got 250,000 Dead Doctors he said
your group's too small so they looked at
250,000 dead doctors they say doctors
don't live to be 58 they died 62 they
still don't live to be 75.5 like the
average couch potato we actually reran
this again using the entire obituary
history for 1996 and for the entire 1996
of all the doctors dying in 1996 with
all the Medical Treatments and drugs and
and procedures and everything and
transplants doctors and in that study
lived to be 70 still 5 and a half years
short of the average couch potato in
America so they still have never proven
that Doctors live as long as everybody
else and that's why Dead Doctors Don't
Lie now if you do everything right how
old can you live to be is it worth all
the effort I believe it is here's one
Christian mortson from San Rafel
California in August of 1995 turned 113
August of 1996 he turned 114 he's still
going strong certainly can live to be
smokes a couple of cigars a day like
George Burns who also lived to be over
hundred certainly was I guess the only
exercise George Burns ever did was put
the cigars in his mouth this gal here
Dora rathebe from South Africa in July
of 1995 turned 114 and when she was
asked by the media Dora what do you
attribute Your Health and Longevity to
she did not say that we owe it all to
our annual physical our our HMO she said
I ate Locust every day you know a little
grasshopper she's not a vegetarian she
eats little animals pumpin seeds taurise
meat wild herbs dried fruit and starts
each day with a cup of coffee this G
here Margaret SKS from Radford Virginia
in 1994 was the oldest documented living
American when she died at age of 115
fell over and fractured her hip three
weeks later she was dead from
complications of osteoporosis a simple
Calcium deficiency and we'll talk more
about this in a minute unfortunately
this is not unusual 75% of all Americans
over the age of 65 who fracture Hipp or
major leg bone don't live 90 days they
die pneumonia pulmonary embolism stroke
and other complication of that fracture
Susie Brunson according to her family in
December of 1994 was the oldest American
when she died at age of 123 and they
based her claim on her birth date
December 25th 1870 which was recorded in
the family bible then this fellow here
Francisco Barrison away a chap Arina
October 1995 he was from a little town
outside of bogat Columbia turned 125
when he was asked by the media Francisco
what do you attribute Your Health and
Longevity too he said well I drink a
gallon of goats milk every day also it's
kind of fascinating in his birthday
announcement this is not an obituary
this is a birthday announcement said
that over 40 years ago his Physicians
told him he only had a couple of months
to live so he had his son's build him a
coffin and uh he's been waking up every
morning for more than 40 years sitting
by that coffin waiting to
die good night time comes he goes to bed
wakes up the next morning sits by the
coffin waits to die now he's still going
strong and all the doctors who told him
that more than 40 years ago are long
since dead now this fellow here Hamudi
El Abdullah from Syria died age 133 and
he was still fathering children after
the age of 100
he um remarried for the fourth time when
he was aged 80 fathered four boys five
girls nine children after the age of 80
with the same wife and we add up the
pregnancies and the breastfeeding the
time in between pregnancies he was still
fathering children after the age of 100
now this very next one is my very very
favorite this gal maumi dusy from Iran
according to the Rocky Mountain news
wire Services out of Denver and the
Iranian news agency this was January of
1995 she died at age of 161 now you have
to give a certain amount of credibility
to the obituary report that she died at
age 161 because she was survived by six
living children ranging in age from 120
to 128 they hadn't even left home to go
to college
yet now her oldest son Golam said his
mother had never visited a doctor are
taking any chemical medications during
her life did take a few herbs so if you
kind of think about it every one of
these people who Liv to be over a
hundred 120 130 160 these people are not
from United States or Canada or Germany
or England kind of interesting isn't it
they most of them are from third world
countries they're furthest away from
medical help and they live to be old so
that we're beginning to collect
information here the last one we want to
look at the National Geographic Society
a very respected group of uh people
scientist and so forth and support
groups for science uh comes out with a
monthly magazine the National Geographic
magazine of course and they uh in
January of 1973 came out with a Nifty
special issue on longevity they they
looked at cultures whose people live to
be 120 and they documented the oldest
living human being that they could find
based on their criteria this fellow by
the name of shirali misala from
azerbijan a little country just south of
Russian Georgia and Western Russia today
they documented him as being 167 years
old remember this is the National
Geographic Society not the national
inquir 167 years of age and they had a
half page picture of him actually
harvesting tea leaves in a Tea
Plantation still working 8 hours a day 6
days a week when he's 167 5 months later
May of 1973 R molof turns 168 goes out
and H the garden for reporters to show
how vigorous he is now for at least 50
maybe 70 years medical doctors in
America have been poo pooing the idea
that you could live well beyond 100 you
know people who lived 115 120 they were
one in six billion it wasn't something
that everybody could look forward to and
anybody who tried to teach people how to
live to be 110 120 140 were considered
charlatans and quacks and taking
advantage of older people I was glad to
see this come out this was a news
article in the USA Today newspaper in
October of 2000 and it was based on a
article in the journal science very
respectable journal and what they said
was forget 100 try living past
120 humans possess a maximum life
expectancy longer than 120 years which
had been the long theorized medical
limit in fact lifespans appear to be
increasing over time with no end in
sight now the cute part of this is now
that there's no doubt about it everybody
agrees that human beings including
Americans have the genetic capacity to
live well beyond 120 doctors want to
take credit for it the things that have
actually increased our longevity from 45
average lifespan in 1895 to 75.5 today
which is an increase of about 30 and a
half years are sewers and good clean
water public health things we don't have
Calera and leptospirosis and
tuberculosis in our food supply and our
water supply anymore we have Meat
Inspection we have public water works
and things we have sewers these are the
things that have extended our lifespan
then there's this salt thing now whether
you believe it or not this medical Dogma
has really caused a lot of problems in
America how many you ever heard that
using the salt shaker is bad you're
going to get hypertension right you're
going to get heart disease and stroke
what's the first thing a good farmer
puts out for his livestock a salt
blocker Salt Lick isn't it there's
nobody out in the pasture telling a cow
she's limited to one lick a
day I refuse to believe that my human
patients are dumber than a cow say look
go ahead and pick up a salt shaker and
you're going to see the lightning won't
strike you you can go ahead and salt
your food to tast you can salt your body
nothing bad is going to happen and 98%
of my patients love it they bring me
hundreds of new patients every month who
want you salt and not feel guilty about
it and 2% the bean counters they say now
w we love you and respect you we have
this High pric cardiologist that says
you're flying in the face of all the
wedded medical evidence you can't tell
people that um they can use a salt
shaker because you're going to kill them
with high blood pressure and heart
disease and stroke and I've been
Vindicated in this belief this was
actually a study that was published in
the New York Times May 22nd 1996 and
this study was abstracted from jamama
the Journal of the American Medical
Association the most prestigious medical
journal in the world according to
themselves now in this particular
journal A Dr Alexander Gordon Logan who
is an epidemiologist and cardiologist on
the teaching staff of the medical school
at the University of Toronto up in
Canada and he took 56 existing studies
on hypertension or high blood pressure
and restriction of salt combined the
data from these 56 studies which
included 355 people he threw away all
the conclusions and reevaluated the
larger group and what he found out was
this if you have normal blood pressure
and you restrict salt it will not
prevent you from getting heart disease
or high blood pressure if you have
hypertension or high blood pressure and
your restrict salt 97% of those with
high blood pressure or hypertension who
restrict salt will not get any
measurable benefit 97% will not get any
measurable benefit zero 2 to 5% get
measurable benefit but it's not
significant they're only able to reduce
their blood pressure by 3.7 millim of
mercury so here's what Dr Alexander
Gordon Logan said in jamama May 22nd
1996 he said you might as well go ahead
and salt your food to taste it's a
meaningless exercise don't get paranoid
about salt it has nothing to do with
blood pressure problems there has never
been one single iota of proof that
restricting salt has any benefit it's
just one of those medical myths he
called it but I'm going to call it a
medical cocka now if it's not salt what
causes high blood pressure well it's not
salt first of all because salt is an
essential nutrient has a combination of
sodium and chloride both of which you
need and according to the American Heart
Association the minimum daily
requirement for 150 lb person for salt
each day is a heaping teaspoon 69 grams
of salt a day now the Japanese who live
longer than we do the Japanese who live
4.1 years longer than we do and have
half the cancer rate they eat 12 G of
salt a day they eat three times the salt
we do and they live four years longer
have half the cardiovascular disease
rate and half the cancer rate we do and
yet they eat three times as much salt as
we do so you're beginning to put the
puzzle together that doctors really
don't know what they're talking about
that's why Dead Doctors Don't Lie well
if it's not the salt and if it's not
genetic what is it well it's actually
just a simple mineral deficiency raise
your hand you ever heard that
cholesterol is bad and you got to get it
low in your blood you got to have low
cholesterol diet otherwise you're going
to get heart disease right doctors would
like to blame all cardiovas disease on
cholesterol we've known for 75 years in
the animal industry that cholesterol is
not a boogeyman there's not a single
disease is caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides if you can
find me one I'll give you a million
dollars in small bills in any offshore
account you want there's not a single
disease is caused by elevated blood
cholesterol or triglycerides elevated
blood cholesterol and triglycerides are
really just a warning signal much like a
fever fevers don't cause infections but
when you have an infection with a
bacteria a virus a fungus maybe a
parasite you can get a fever you can
have a broken leg and get a fever you
can have cancer and get a fever you can
have liver disease and get a fever
babies get a fever when they teeth and
so you have to kind of sort it out when
somebody comes into a doctor's office
with a fever you have to say well okay
here's my whole list called a
differential diagnosis all the things
that cause fever if they're 80 years old
you can quickly rule out teething
right but the rest of you may have to do
some lab tests for any rate the same
thing is true for elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides when you
have elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides it might mean that you
have hypothyroidism or low functioning
thyroid gland you could have diabetes
you could have deficiencies of nasin
chromium vadium the essential fatty
acids you could have liver disease all
kinds of reasons why you might have
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides but they in themselves
don't cause any problems now the eskimos
above the Arctic Circle have a
traditional diet there 98% red meat and
blubber uh they whale meat whale blubber
walrus meat walrus blubber seal meat
seal blubber bare meat bare fat there's
not a single Eskimo above the Arctic
Circle that has a Mr juice man juicer
beats our ganly grown
broccoli their average cholesterol
ranges from 250 to 350 and yet they're
legendary for not getting cardiovascular
disease until they come down to the
lower 48 and eat like us then when they
get the cardiovascular disease they go
back home to die up above the Arctic
Circle they start eating whale blubber
again it goes away well learning all
that I felt very confident in telling my
patients look we're going to do
something different my goal as a
physician is to have my patients die at
an average age of 100 I don't want my
patients dying at 75.5 I want to give
them another 25 years I want the average
lifespan for my patients to be 100 and
we're going to do something different if
you want to do everything that all the
other doctors and patients are doing I
want you to go to them because I don't
want you to lower my average right we're
going to do something different it's
just real simple my favorite disease is
arthritis I love arthritis and the
reason why I love arthritis is it's easy
to fix and when you can fix something as
horrible and as debilitating as painful
and as expensive and as miserable as
arthritis you get kind of excited about
this concept of preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition and so I tell
people about this arthritis thing all
the time so let's have a quick look at
arthritis uh number one 75 to 80% of all
Americans over the age of 50 get
arthritis to one degree or one type or
another and according to the CDC the
Center for Disease Control 35 to 50
million baby boomers are going to get
arthritis in the next 7 to 10 years and
there's not a single medical treatment
designed to prevent or fix it aspirin
certainly doesn't fix arthritis cause
gastric bleeding and death tanol doesn't
fix arthritis causes 50,000 cases of
kidney failure each year 5 th000 which
are so severe you need a kidney
transplant then there's ibuprofen ad
vill and leave these things don't fix
arthritis and they cause liver disease
and 2 to 5% of the users including liver
ceros even if you don't drink and then
there's Methotrexate and gold shots
these things don't fix arthritis they
subdue your bone marrow so you can't
make normal platelets and white blood
cells and then you have the granddaddies
of all the medical treatments for
arthritis prazone and cortisone they
don't fix arthritis they subdue your
immune system which leaves you open to
diseases far far more horrible than
arthritis and prazone and cortisone
accelerate the loss of minerals from
your bone something you don't want when
you have osteoporosis and arthritis now
when these prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and uh I I
never like to send my patients in for
the joint replacement surgery because
they never work out well in fact many
times you're worse off after the surgery
than you were before the surgery the
advantage my patients have always had is
that I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and so I always used to tell
my patients look we have all these
nutritional formulas designed to prevent
and cure diseases in animals including
arthritis and so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis formula is
designed to prevent and cure arthritis
and pigeons and turkeys dogs cats sheeps
pigs horses cows lions tigers and bears
to human use it was no surprise to me it
works just as well in humans as it does
in animals because it was designed to
prevent and cure arthritis and pigs and
I've literally seen tens of thousands of
people who've had a regrowth of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone Foundation bone matrix
doesn't matter if they're 20 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 I've seen people 97 years old
regrow caragen bone even if they had
bone to- bone arthritis if there's blood
supply to that joint and that bone they
will regrow uh bone and carage well of
course Harvard Medical School goes
berserk when you say stuff like that W
you can't say those things the only
thing left for people when they get bone
to bone arthritis is joint replacement
surgery and I I'd agree with him if the
only raw materials you're using is
Tylenol and aspirin and prazone and
cortisone we've learned over 50 years
that you can't regrow carage and bone
using those things one of the basic
things of course the Harvard Medical
School jumped on to and they said this
is so ridiculous that this couldn't work
and so they took 29 patients arthritis
patients who had failed to respond in
any way to heroic medical treatment for
arthritis over 15 to 20 years they took
them off all their medication wasn't
working for them anyway lined them up
for joint replacement surgery and they
said look for 90 days before we do the
surgery they gave him a heaping
tablespoon full of ground up chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning for 90 days they were sort of
chuckling in their beer saying nothing's
going to happen well here's what
happened in 10 days these people people
these 29 people had complete relief of
pain inflammation something they hadn't
had in 15 to 20 years in 30 days they
could Now open up a new pickle jar that
had never been open without pain to the
fingers wrists elbows and shoulders in
90 days 28 of the 29 were clinically
cured now this is from Harvard Medical
School in the Boston VA that meant that
they had complete return to the range of
motion all the pain inflammation was
gone in their fingers and toes and hips
and knees and their neck and certainly
many of them still had knots on their
fingers because it was only 90 days and
you'd think they'd call me up up these
professors you know of medicine from
Harvard Medical School and from the
Boston VA and say look wall we have to
apologize to you we've been bad mouthing
you for 20 years and why don't you come
up to Boston let's talk about the whole
thing here's what they said quote after
3 months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote chicken cartilage had
become a drug in 90
days now why would that happen well
because you can't patent chicken carage
and uh they convinced at the US patent
office that they were using a drug to do
this study and they actually got a use
patent on chicken carage and you to for
3500 bucks a month can get Harvard
Medical school's chicken carage in a
capsule for arthritis of course
cartilage has condr and sulfate in it
glucosamine sulfate collagen these are
all the basic raw materials to rebuild
carage and Bone raise your hand if you
know what the red warning light is for
on the dashboard of a car truck back
before we had dials showing temperatures
and things they used to use the red
warning light right it was called The
Idiot light and when that red warning
light came on it meant that your engine
was heating up you didn't have enough
coolant or oil or maybe you broke a fan
belt or split a radiator hose and a
reasonable person would would pull the
vehicle car or truck over the side of
the road and deal with the problem so he
didn't burn the engine up even even a
Mercedes would burn up if you didn't
have enough coolant and oil and a fan
belt and radiator hose then of course
the village idiot that's why they call
the Village Idiot light or the idiot
light they'd be driving along they'd see
that red warning light come on they say
I don't have time to deal with this so
they whip out their plowers they cut the
wire of the red warning light they keep
on driving even a Mercedes will burn up
if it doesn't have oil cooling a fan
belt and radiator H right and so you
really have to be The Village Idiot to
do that nobody in the right mind would
do that to their vehicle how many of you
know what pain is far raise your hand if
you know what pain is far that's pretty
good most of you know that pain is the
red warning light for your body when you
get pain in your foot your ankle your
leg your knee your hip your back your
shoulders elbows wrist and fingers your
body saying don't use those joints don't
use those bones don't use those muscles
until you fix them it's absolutely
criminal absolutely criminal for a
doctor to write you prescription for a
pain reliever an anti-inflamm or muscle
relaxing or any of those combinations
without rebuilding the bones and the
joints and the cartilage at the same
time if they just give you a pain
reliever just give you an
anti-inflammatory and our muscle
relaxing without rebuilding the joints
and the bones at the same time all
they're doing is cutting the wire of the
red warning light you're going to wear
those bones and joints and cartilage out
faster and faster and faster it's
actually a negative to be taking
painkillers and anti-inflammatories
without rebuilding the joints and the
bones at the same time the reason why I
say no carbonated drinks and I've been
doing that since 1964
is because carbonated drinks actually
will neutralize your stomach acid and
you cannot efficiently absorb minerals
digest protein or absorb vitamin B12
without stomach acid you have to have
stomach acid like battery acid doctors
have the criminal belief that you don't
need stomach acid and they give you all
these drugs get rid of your stomach acid
ant acids and they give you drugs that
stop producing stomach acid right they
don't want you to have stomach acid
absolutely criminal you can't digest
food and absorb food without stomach
acid I know most of you knew that
carbonated drinks neutralized stomach
acid if you remember back 25 50 75 years
ago when somebody would ask your doctor
and say look I just ate a i overate i
overate a Thanksgiving dinner and I have
heartburn and indigestion what do I do
that was before they had Zantac they say
well take some seven up drink some
ginger ale drink some club soda take
take some uh sparkling water because the
carbonation will neutralize your stomach
gas and give you some relief in a wood
now if you do that three times a year
drink a carbonated drink three times a
year for thanks giving and Christmas and
Easter because you overeat during those
holidays that's okay you're going to
survive but when you're drinking 2 3 4 5
6 8 10 carbonated drinks a day you're
not going to survive because over the
long haul you will not be able to absorb
the nutrients you're going to get some
horrible combination of terrible
diseases this came out June of 2000 and
this is a Harvard study on 460 Junior
High School girls 9th and 10th grade and
what they found out was that those
Junior High School girls who drank one
non-cola carbonated drink every every
day they increase their risk of
fractures and osteoprosis as a teenager
by 300% they found out that if they
drank one carbonated Cola drink a cola
carbonated drink every day they increase
the risk of fractures and osteoprosis as
a teenager by
500% now do you think that this is more
dangerous for teenagers or adults it's
much more dangerous for adults because
you only have 25% bone matrix and you're
very very slow to recover where
teenagers have 40% bone matrix and they
can recover in a week's time we learned
in 195 7 from a turkey study uh where
they took 250,000 turkeys and they put
them on a complete turkey pellet trying
to get them to finish for Market within
a few days or a week or so of each other
and in the first 13 weeks fully half of
them 125,000 of them died farmers were
out there every morning they picked them
up every morning by the bushel basket
full took them to the state Diagnostic
lab to see what they died from when they
opened them up every one of them had
died of a ruptured a Arctic aneurysm and
one of the clever pathologist says
that's got to be due to a copper
deficiency because copper is required to
manufacture the elastic fibers of
arteries and skin and other tissues and
the mechanism of an aneurysm is
identical to the mechanism of a balloon
on a weak and Wall of a tire you know
when you hit a Chuck hole with your tire
and you break the cords the internal
pressure blows a balloon you overload
that tire with weight or heat it up on a
highway it blows out same way with an
aneurysm when you have a copper
deficiency you get a break down of the
elastic fibers uh in that artery the
internal pressure even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon in that
artery and a balloon in an artery is
called an aneurysm and of course if it's
in a strategic place like the brain
crowded artery the coronary arteries the
large arteries the aart pulmonary artery
renal arteries they blow out you die
suddenly uh just like you've been shot
well they got excited about this they
double the amount of copper in these um
pellets the next year they tried to
raise 500,000 turkeys and they did not
lose a single one from a ruptured
aneurysm they went from a 50% loss to a
0% loss just by adding a little bit of
copper to those pellets so they said
well maybe the same thing is true for
humans and in 19 uh 58 they started
looking at copper deficiency in various
species of animals and humans and here's
what they found out the very first
symptom of copper deficiency is white
gray and silver hair copper is required
as a co-actor to manufacture hair
pigment doesn't matter if it's blonde
red brown or black hair and I see a lot
of copper deficiency in this room I can
almost tell you which people men and
women who have colored their hair get
pretty good at that being a physician
and you don't want to be like a medical
doctor and just treat the symptoms if
you're just coloring your hair you're
treating the symptoms you need to do the
basic thing of take some colloidal
copper